[Music]
all right let's go to jessica in
wilkesboro north carolina what's up
jessica how are you
hey dr john i'm doing
pretty good how are you this morning i'm
good that sounds fantastic um inside of
baseball we had some uh phone line
issues probably on our part and so now
we are squared up and you sound like a
human that's awesome jessica
okay so you're filling me in you've got
some chaos in your house what's going on
yes eight weeks ago i had twin girls and
um just a lot of changes there
and my husband's been struggling so i'm
just trying to see how i can help him
out with this very cool so walk me
through
one congratulations on having two twin
girls and you've got two other kids
right so you got a total of four
yeah four girls and the oldest one is
how old
six wow okay so people email me all the
time on the internets or they they slide
into my dms and they tell me that i say
the words um
you're in it
too much and so i won't say that but you
are super in it man wow okay four six
and under that's a lot okay so how's
your husband struggling
well just we've had a lot of changes
going on this year with the pandemic and
we had deaths in the family of our
grandparents um the move we moved in the
summer where'd you move from like a new
state or a new town
just a new town yeah we moved um just
about an hour away from where we were
living
okay
oh man i've got a whole thing about that
um okay so
when you say he's struggling what does
that look like
just dealing with some depression like
just anxiety um
fear of you know supplying uh for us for
the family financially
um
you know just a lot of doubts and
worthlessness feeling you know not
worthy worthy or
just feeling
like he's not doing a good job gotcha
where does he get that message from
mostly himself i feel like her
um you know it's just thoughts that
are being put into his head or
attacks on him that
are coming from
you know
things that
think they're gonna happen but then they
don't end up happening um meaning like
people people are gonna offer him a job
and then they don't come through yeah
okay yeah he has a business that he
started so
he'll have a plan and then it won't you
know follow through and he just gets
really discouraged why um why'd y'all
move we just felt the lord calling us to
this area
specifically what does that mean when
you say the lord calls us like what does
that mean
we felt
a really
strong pull to this area it's it's a
prayer
it's called prayer mountain and
we have some land here
and so we have some family that live
here but we just felt that
the lord was trying to get us out of the
the city life and more into the country
life with you know
land and an area where we could
raise our children um we could
hunt we could you know
be ourselves um we could just
be more free to be us and not have to
live
under that
city type of lifestyle where we're you
know
always
dealing with loud neighbors or you know
things going on that we don't believe in
um
my coyotes are pretty loud neighbors too
but i get what you're saying so yeah um
is there
i have some ideas but i i want to get a
sense of what you're living with
um you've got these two little babies
and twins are
a lot and you've got two other little
ones who now were the center of the
universe and now they are
understandably having to wipe their own
bottoms and they don't like that
and yeah a lot of this i'm guessing
because you got a somebody who just is
trying to start a new business in a new
little community
a lot of that falls on you and now you
are also
having a weird task of propping up
a depressed husband
walk me through what that feels like
it's just
it feels hard it feels like you know i'm
taking this day by day i'm just trying
to make it through the day or you know
make it through the end of the week or
but i also feel like
i'm not doing a good enough job or being
you know a good enough spouse for him
i'm doing my job by raising the children
you know taking care of the babies
feeding them changing them all those
things that come with the responsibility
of being a mother but also first and
foremost you know your relationship with
your spouse has to be
has to be top priority and you have to
make sure that you're you're on the same
level with your spouse and putting them
first what
what's something is different now and
it's making you nervous what is it
there's something there's something
below what you're telling me is what i'm
getting at there's something else yeah
that this is all new to me like this is
all
a change yeah it's a big um
it's a big change and we had full-time
jobs we both worked full-time at our old
um where we lived and things were
comfortable yeah um but now things are
not so comfortable and the future looks
kind of you know wish-washy
and it looks wish-washy and your husband
thinks he's failing because he's not
making enough money
because people he can't count on people
because he thought this move to the
country was going to heal everything and
we're it was all going to make what what
does he feel like he's missing
it's just a lot of
like pressure um
he
he had this job that he did for somebody
in their house
and now they've come back and they're
not happy or this is falling apart or
this is this way sure and he just feels
you know like he's not doing a good job
yeah is it is it honest to say that he
didn't do a good job on that one
no that's not true okay okay anything he
touches turns to gold you know he's very
proud craftsman okay uh very crafty so
yeah it's it's just
something it's hard let me back all the
way out here here's a couple of things i
want y'all to
keep in your mind and some things y'all
can do
to
kind of
not get through this season but to make
this season something really powerful
and important
and yeah this touch is close to home for
me because i just went through this
about a year ago
moving from downtown downtown i mean it
was bustling it was awesome we were
walking everywhere the city was always
going
to now we live on some acres out in
like the woods woods
um
like coyotes running across the yard
woods
yeah um right
i
i hear this a lot from people who make
this transition that they think whenever
i get there wherever there is
finally things will be okay
and i will be a little less anxious
about the state of the economy and i'll
be a little less anxious about supply
chain issues and i'll be a little less
worried about covet and i'll finally get
out of these dumb schools because then
i'll be able to whatever
and if
we
we play one side of that equation over
and over and we tell ourselves the story
we tell ourselves the story we tell
ourselves a story and then every single
thing we see
backs up our story that we tell
ourselves
every we forget the 50 emails that are
positive that the school sends and they
send the one that makes us crazy and we
go c
and we start looking everywhere for data
points they're going to back up our
story
and then we move
and some p and this also works if you're
going in reverse this this is if you're
gonna break up with somebody and get
somebody new or you're cheating on your
spouse whatever the thing is
we think that when we get over there
wherever there is finally things will be
okay
and the worst part about any sort of
transition is that you go with you
and if you were anxious when you lived
in a city you're going to be super
anxious
when you're living out in the middle of
the country
and if you were
didn't like customer interaction you're
really good with your hands and you
didn't like customer interaction your
old job you can't wait to just do it on
your own well on your own it's all
customer interaction you know i mean so
we missed the good parts we miss the
tough parts we that we just look for the
parts that that validate our story
um the second thing that i
underestimated
is it's a lonely out in the country
it's lonely
and i had neighbors i didn't even like
them all but i had them
and there i had one neighbor dogs are
always barking bark and bark they drove
me crazy now it's just silence and their
silence was awesome for a few months and
i kind of missed the dog you know what i
mean so it's a it's a bose and um but i
got really really lonely
um
and then there's this weird thing about
moving an hour away
and here's my little hypothesis about
this there's no research to back this up
i think moving an hour away or 45
minutes away
is really hard
because you tell yourself that things
will mostly be the same
we can still come visit them we'll still
go to this restaurant we'll still go see
these people
because it's just an hour away
and you don't realize there's no chance
you're doing that
and if you move 10 hours away you have
to pack up and move to a new place but
you kind of stretch it out when you move
an hour away is that fair
right yes it's like this it'll be both
and and it's just not and i don't know
you get this this this middle space here
so here's
here i'll just say what me and my wife
have had to do okay
um
one
have you called out his depression
yes and what does he say to that
that he just doesn't feel like it's
something that he could talk to somebody
about um
you know it's not becoming of a man to
to talk about his feelings
kind of thing and what i'll tell you is
it's not becoming of a man to melt your
wife
and it's not becoming of a man to starve
his four daughters of connection and
it's not becoming of a man to be in a
home and not present
and so the most manly thing he could do
would be to go take care of himself
yeah and i'd love for him to call me
because i'll take him to task over that
nonsense
the most
manly thing he could do is take care of
himself
and i work with navy seals behind closed
door i mean to work with some folks
behind closed doors
and the baddest of the bad
and yeah they take care of themselves
okay so
here's a
here's what y'all have to do that i
don't think you have
you all need to have some sort of and i
know it's almost impossible with two
eight week olds or eight month olds
you have to get
away
even for two hours
and do a here's where we are now
conversation
it sounds like you all ran to a new
world and you didn't stop you just kept
life kept going
and it kept going and it's still trying
to just keep going but everything has
changed
and so if you were in
if you were a navy seal and you had a
mission and you went out on that mission
and all of a sudden your lead humvees
blew up and you found yourself another
you have to stop for a second and say
okay our objective now is different it
was to go get the bad guys now it's to
just get home and our everything's
changed you all have to have that
conversation
and that will look like this
getting out some paper and writing down
here's all the things that i miss about
our old house here's all the things i'm
so glad
that we're away from
here is where i feel like i'm failing
here's where i think i'm doing good you
got to put all that on paper and get it
out of each other's heads and now
there's this there's this tension
between each other because you don't
know how to lean into him
and
because it's i don't know it's like a
little bit reactory it's a little bit
like put your hand in quicksand and then
he feels that you're not there and then
he feels like he's feeling and this
thing just loops on itself right
and now you are starting to wonder what
am i doing wrong as a wife and
he like i should be able to say the
right thing that's going to snap him out
of all this
and he should be saying
i shouldn't have a depressed wife that's
my fault and now y'all end up way far
apart so somebody's gotta just say hey
we gotta acknowledge this call it out
write down what sucks about this new
season what we miss what we love
and
you've gotta start modeling the only
thing you can do here you can't fix it
let me put it that way you've got to
start modeling i'm taking care of myself
and if that means i'm going to get a
babysitter that we can't even afford
because i'm going to go see a counselor
i'm going to go talk to a pastor that i
trust whatever that looks like i'm going
to go do that
and here's the thing that
i hope this isn't controversial good
grief who never knows what the
internet's
the reason i i
wanted you to dig in a little bit on
this phrase god's calling us
i hear that a lot all over the country
and two things happen
one
people make big crazy life moves
and they say god told us to
and they don't take ownership of the
fact that we really wanted to move we
want to get out of there
and when we can say god's telling us to
or some some big universe is calling us
whatever that means
we often don't do the planning required
do we have enough money do we have a
plan do we have any sort of income are
we gonna be able to pay the light bill
and not to say that um
you know faith isn't obviously if it's
important
but we don't do the planning and then
when we show up somewhere and it's
uncomfortable
it melts everything it melts our
relationships it melts faith it melts
everything
and so
i have i have no doubt
i'm never gonna get between you and your
faith ever
but i want you to have faith and plan
like have faith and make really
sound financial decisions in relational
decisions what does that mean
he's trying to get a business off the
ground he may have to deliver pizzas at
night in this new community he may have
to mow lawns and cut down trees too for
a season
and that's not going to feel like
quote-unquote i got called to this thing
where i'm grinding but that may be the
season you're in because we got to pay
bills
and that's where you're going to get
these little wins and begin to get our
feet underneath us does that make sense
yeah yeah totally yeah i understand
the big thing is don't just let all of
this change run over you and just try to
get to the next thing you all got to
stop and acknowledge everything you
gotta grieve it we miss this stuff we
made a big move this is our new world
and now we can build a new plan moving
forward and that's so so hard
and what's gonna be really hard for you
you're so you're so great what's gonna
be hard for you
is you can't fix him and you can't help
him
i mean you can help him you can love him
you can connect but you can't fix him
he has to make some decisions about him
being well about him gonna maybe let
this dream die for a minute or do this
dream on the side because he's got to
make some money or
maybe
he had these dreams of a big house and
he's gonna have to have a small house
for the next decade and and fill in the
blank we have to be honest about those
things and he's gonna have to make the
hard choice to change his thoughts and
to change his actions and be disciplined
in taking care of himself in his
relationships and that's hard
and so i hope he sees this i want to
tell you brother you are worth being
well
you're worth taking care of yourself and
i don't hear any more nonsense about
what's unbecoming of a man
all of that is nonsense the most
becoming thing is taking care of
yourself and being well if you're not
okay you're not okay man i've been there
every guy i know has been there
the courageous thing is the brave thing
is
are we going to be vulnerable and go get
help
that's the question
jessica he's lucky to have you
you all get away and start grieving and
then we'll start get you and then we'll
get to making plans in the future